today Matt is cooking us his version of
a sexy steak bun me what hi this is your
your tools mate
you got a microwave all right you got
this random scale Ashley it's all got
ash fine a lot of Asian people who don't
know this but the dishwasher is not ever
used to wash dishes it's just there as a
dish rack I did the same think of that
these cast iron pots and I just did it
and it came out hell arrested yeah I
have a kid only thought that that was
what that was useful didn't didn't have
any clue and until I went to a college
and we started using it I start to
realize how amazing this [ __ ] machine
is like you generally just scrub your
dishes and then you throw it in there
and then after you leave it in there for
about an hour and a half it comes out
squeaky clean and hot crazy and I'm
explaining this to people like they
don't know about it but I did it so hey
[ __ ] you just the other day I made this
thing you guys heard of it's called
peanut butta and jelly sandwich it was
delicious
could you make those hot pockets ha ha
ha ha ha
less cereal just a shooter fella leggo
my eggo Lean Cuisine ha ha ha
now I'm coming I was joking around like
I could cook a few things here and there
one of my favorite dishes actually is
if you have I know people from New
Orleans I know no not real gumbo your
rooms not dark enough [ __ ] you I got
[ __ ] to our students or some [ __ ]
room suck my nuts it's so interesting
too because you know like when you eat
you would cook with your friends and you
guys have your own pot Luck's like you
could tell somebody who's a a cook and
you're somebody who knows how to cook a
dish you having a great example is Rob
all right Robbie's a don't read anything
next I don't know if I would touch
anything that Rob touches I [ __ ] love
you rob it's just you look like there
are people out on Skid Row that look
cleaner than you
[ __ ] I just love watching a hot piece of
meat hit our hot pan it's delicious my
mouth started watering and you know one
thing that I actually learned from that
from this is well I always saw it on TV
there was I put a lot of oil in the pan
but the way or the amount of oil that
Matt put it when I got to see it in
person then I started to realize why all
these chefs have such a nice crust on
their steaks is because they're
essentially almost it's almost like a
really thin deep-fried on that first
contact of beef so it gets that crispy
like my hard reaction where you get that
nice like beef crusty thank you Matt for
that tip in my kitchen nothing has ever
been cooked like this in my kitchen
don't expect anything else like this out
of me oh that's it
San Pedro how's it pronounced that's fun
Carol people keep pronouncing it at San
Pedro my Dubai manager when he first
came here he goes oh you know it's a
really cool place with loose tea leaves
I like Los Feliz your bust and oh right
David with the San Diego he goes yeah
but me the La Jolla area like La Jolla
said La Jolla look at me like I love gum
yeah La Jolla do yes I am in some of my
dance classes I had kids like named Jose
what's way yeah Seuss
and Jesus yeah hey soos is Jesus bro
yeah all right getting corrected my
second visit I know that's what I'm
afraid of like when I get older and I
have kids right
and then my kid picks he's hella smarter
than me oh [ __ ] my sentence was wrong
like hey Dad
it's actually I'm doing well hey shut
the [ __ ] up and go to your room it's
about that are you doing well now you
know I can't say that I'm a great chef
or a cook and the reason why is because
other people who say there are really
good cooks it doesn't mean that you're a
good cook because you just make a
specific dish very well meaning that you
follow the structures well to the point
where you can make that really good dish
but if somebody put a bunch of random
ingredients in front of you can you
create something amazing with it
I personally can't do that so I'm one of
those like instruction chefs were
there's like I say like 10 or 12 people
that can make really well and I make it
well every time and people think I'm a
dumbass but that is actually the 2016
version of having a big dick chef skills
we use a lot Jilly's that never we work
in one of my cooks didn't wear any
gloves right you spend all these chilies
and all these chilies it's fine and then
sometimes it doesn't come out but the
capsaicin stays in your bloodstream and
it comes out with you sweat uh-huh so it
goes this girl's place right and they're
getting it on and all of a sudden the
other sweats get hot and sweaty right
and all of a sudden she's like oh
freaking Chili's only with me oh no like
burning down south oh my god that's
[ __ ] hilarious fire [ __ ] that's what
that is that straight fire [ __ ] pig
skin deep-fried and it puffs up like
that what would the Mexican Translation
be keep that on keep that on
[ __ ]
chichi roads are born it's basically
deep-fried pieces of pig skin that pop
up when you put it into the oil oh when
I was a kid and I used to eat that stuff
at first I didn't even know it was
pigskin I just thought it was this
just cracker what is the enemy's
translation of what we're eating steak
buy me a bun me is a delicious this is a
set sandwich let's put on a bad guy
so if you don't know Vietnam has a lot
of French influence so if you if you had
a bond me you realize that inside one of
the main ingredients at you get is pate
which is French influence as well
including a baguette
so it's video music French wrapped up
into this delicious crunchy piece of
bread with some pizza vegetables meat
and their separate cetera
look at this I'm excited my [ __ ] tell
your Colonel again [ __ ] what oh wait yes
yeah let's take it over to this is a
table of Italy mom bye bye [ __ ] how do
you say in Spanish huh La Table
so we got a buddy from that which I made
with this delicious gotta see your steak
put a little bit of garlic in there and
the butter and he pasted it in the pan
as well the bunny was super crunchy
because he totes you in the pen and he
added the kewpie mail with a little bit
of the jalapeno and some of the the
herbs and vegetables
absolutely delicious too because it was
the fatty steak and it kind of you broke
that up with what's a citrusy kind of
fresh bite that you got from the salad
it was delicious man I wish I could make
them myself
I tried actually it tastes like [ __ ] I'm
excited
well everybody cheers cheers Cheers
so how am I doing with my life
sandwiches to me is like the
quintessential example of the perfect
bite you have that crunchy bread which
adds that nice texture to it it's
buttery from the butter and then you
have this protein which will force you
need a good bite of any type of protein
whether it's beef pork fish or whatever
and then you could add vegetables to
which as your vegetation so it's like
sex in a package that you put in the
mouth it's a [ __ ] do you have any
buff chefs like super fit chefs that
work for you yeah yeah I don't think if
I were a really good food and the chef
is rip yeah don't cook much without
straight-up just to put this in
perspective if you're a chef and you
have a six pack you obviously suck ass
at cooking you know I stay fat is to
give all the other men a chance in the
world I got a bomb-ass personality you
can have me with the six pounds game
over dude every time I walk in while the
Dukes be like [ __ ] baby's here man the
whole my girl's super tight I know I'm
doing like funny fat baby stuff and
that's for my personal health but the
reason why I was against being too fit
is because I just want to keep it fair
to the other guys you
saying like I'm sexy and I'm funny and I
can cook what what more did you need
that's [ __ ] boat or in a package do I
like food food with fat always tastes
better you know soluble fiber if you eat
it with that
soluble fiber helps flush that fat out
in it takes fat within your body out too
oh really so if I put like submit Musel
yeah no you eat it I don't know what the
[ __ ] of soluble fiber is if you like
beans and legumes and like okra has it
like fruit like apples and stuff like
that eat it with your fat it'll kind of
help push mm-hmm basically it takes the
cluster within your body up and whatever
you're eating goes with it too [ __ ]
hate okra no have the okra okra so now
be eating five all day
I believe branch is a tree to make sure
my steak come out nice and Dukey we're
gonna start kicking yeah I want to but
once again after today I still have the
ingredients I'm gonna try to recreate
what Matt made I guarantee you is gonna
taste like [ __ ] I gave you so growing up
there was a few cooking inspirations
that I had Julia Child's recipes Shaklee
pan please don't die yet cuz I [ __ ]
love this guy if you don't know who can
can't cook is you should end your life
one cut another cut turner outside one
can roll hold it back hold it this don't
everyone it's come a whole chicken blood
comes out and a whole little room comes
out like this and attend on on this side
comes out like that please come out and
then turn it around side and this
gentleman should get chicken bar Luke
comes out like this and a whole lotta
bees good chicken back comes out I get
lots of booty terror and comes out like
him nice and done he is the guy who
really put like Asian cooking on the map
he did before all these like super top
chefs were happening yeah yeah Kent
Cooke has this show on PBS I used to
watch religiously as a kid
he kind of taught you how to dissemble
chicken superfast how to shell garlic
and uh I just love the guy his
personality was dope
he's my [ __ ] where is like that don't
stand dumb because we should always say
when you put something in a in hot oil
don't same dunk sites like this done he
will you I love you take a [ __ ]
garlic clove right
this [ __ ] would you be like this
ma'am ma'am is this like this but done
yeah like it just me like I learned
something MVP of the year smack of
garlic and it was peeled in a second
thank you mr. Yan can cook see this I
don't even like cooking rice
should I got the microwave [ __ ] what
y'all laugh now but when you're [ __ ]
hungry of [ __ ] and you got Korean side
dishes and you don't want to cook rice
BAM
that was extra disappointed me we were
connecting about food I told him about
the the cooked rice and just look at me
like this especially whatever man I love
you Pippa - episode just come on up what
the [ __ ] did you buy Bobst microwave
rice for you're a disgrace to all Asian
hey you know what your sandwich was
there's nothing to say these are
attacking you personally by the way [ __ ]
your feet matt is an amazing dude we got
to share a meal with him and actually
got to eat with him with the food that
he made with his hands in my place and a
lot of you guys forget to that cooking
any art and that's what I love about
Matt Matt takes his cooking on another
level of passion
and when you have people who are
passionate about what they do especially
when it comes to food you can taste it
so thank you man coming through man you
are my new friend don't ever be shy to
say what's up to me and if you think I'm
a freakin you're running away too late
RH food we're one